hey guys markiplier here and I wanted
you all to know that the charity
livestream for August is coming this
Saturday the 24th starting at 10 a.m.
Eastern Standard Time if you don't know
what time zone that is for you please
use Google to figure it out for yourself
now we are raising money this month for
Cincinnati Children's Hospital which is
something local that I wanted to do for
awhile because in the past we've done a
lot of charity effort if you don't know
this channel here runs charity
livestreams every month and we've raised
a total of eighty thousand dollars for
various charities which I'm
exceptionally proud of and and this
month were trying to raise 25 thousand
dollars for Cincinnati Children's
Hospital and I've already contacted them
I've gotten the registration set up for
the event so that they know what's going
on so they will have a little bit of
extra support and we'll be able to help
out my own community which I've been
wanting to do for a long time so thank
you guys so much for giving me the
opportunity to do this so that's this
Saturday don't forget this Saturday
10:00 a.m. Eastern Standard Time where
we'll be having Wade will be over here
as per usual bob is still away that's
why there hasn't been many drunk
minecraft stuff Bob is now in North
Carolina so he will not be here but I'll
be getting other youtubers to help out
we'll be getting people in whatever way
we can so hope you'll be there it'll be
over on the twitch channel if you want
to be proactive you can click the link
in the description to follow me on
Twitch that way you'll know exactly when
we go live there are also being
announcements on this channel when we go
live so thank you guys again in other
news do you guys remember cyndago well
if you do you might remember the first
video that they ever did with me in it
was danger in fiction whoa guess what
what danger in fiction too was just
released exactly now ago so if you click
anywhere probably on my beautiful face
you will be taken directly to the video
where you will see this amazing role
that I got to play I really had a lot of
fun doing it so I hope you guys enjoy
also here's a little sneak peek if you
didn't want to go over there right away
this might
the looming presence around Ryan became
more insidious with each page discovered
he would have to find them all in order
to escape this grueling night pretty
cool huh
but you only get to see that little
snippet over here if you want to see the
rest either click my face or click the
link in the description below so thanks
everyone thanks need to go for having me
over there hope I see you guys this
Saturday 10:00 a.m. Eastern Standard
Time whatever way you can be there if
you can't that's ok the donation
information will be available so thank
you guys again for your ongoing support
I'm honored to be able to do this I'm
honored to be able to help out people in
whatever way I can so thanks again
everybody and I will see you this
Saturday bye bye